kayla how are we doing um i
have been um dealing with some
dysfunction in my family
mainly um an issue with my mother
yep hey do me a favor um take a breath
i can already hear it on you and not
even know what you're about to ask i
could already hear it on you
um take a big breath take a big breath
and exhale okay
all right i'm with you thank you
um she uses suicide as a manipulation
tool with
me and my family members okay tell me
about us
the most recent one um it wasn't with me
directly it was with another family
member
and i heard it through them um and was
the context
um they're dealing with their
relationship and i'm just being there
for them
um but she kind of used it to end the
relay
in that conversation and in that um
interaction
um i can't exactly remember the exact
content because i heard it second hand
but it was kind of like
um well i'm just gonna go and kill
myself
and then she leaves the room um has she
ever
done that she ever attempted suicide
before or is this just a move
no i believe it's just a move she's used
it
repetitively um i could say probably a
handful of times
over um the years um but i know this
year
and it has gotten progressively
progressively worse
and i think i've just been more aware of
it because i've been listening to your
show
and i've read boundaries and i just want
to know how to
respond this way by still giving her
love and support
sure so first i want to just thank you
for having
like a just a beautiful heart you're a
good human being
and the world needs more calories in it
because the temptation here is to write
mom off or the temptation here is just
to be a doormat
and you are taking the hard messy right
road which is to navigate all of it
protect your heart protect your mind
protect your family and also love your
mom the best
you can the best she'll allow right so
good for you kayla
um what is your outside of the suicide
threats what is your relationship like
with your mom
do y'all go hang out have coffee
together do you see each other regularly
do you all call once a week what's it
look like
um we're still developing um that
daily interaction i have put it on
myself to kind of reach out to
my parents every week and just kind of
give them a call on the weekend
um it's something that i have struggled
to do
with in the past and i've recently just
moved home
um so you know
uh just closer proximity okay all right
and why are you the one reaching out to
them
do they not want to talk to you and they
just tolerate you or or
do they have other dysfunction going on
in their marriage
yes um i my dad will reach out to me
um i think my mom just struggles with
reaching out
um i know she's going through some
things
um i know my parents are going through
things going through like are they going
through marriage issues they're going
through money issues they're getting
divorced like what are they going
through
um we recently lost a family member
i'm so sorry so i think that's been
hitting them hard yeah
um my sister so oh your sister passed
away recently
yeah two years ago gosh caleb i'm so
sorry
yeah so um our family has gone through
a lot of change yeah that so
sucks i'm so sorry so tell me about your
dad
he's a good guy you love him um he's
good
he's he's strong but he's also going
through
um this past year we've had to be there
for him because he's been going through
some
some mental self challenges he struggles
with
depression and bipolar for for years
um and this year just with the loss of
my sister i think has gotten him
hitting him a lot harder um he's doing
better now
um but i i
yeah so okay so
give me a couple more questions here how
old are you
uh in my 30s okay and do you have
are you married you got kids of your own
uh i'm married
i don't have any kids no mary no kids
okay
so here's a couple of
things we're gonna start way back and
then we'll get kind of granular okay
number one i want you to get with your
husband if he is
um trustworthy in this way not to say
that he's not trustworthy but that
some people are just good at this and
some aren't and that's not a knock on
him
it's just this is a skill and if he's
not the right one
i want you to get with a couple of
girlfriends i think it'd be good to
include him if you can
um even if you say i want you to be a
part of this but i don't want you to say
any words
and my wife has done that with me
actually um
i want you to
mourn the loss of the picture of your
parents
okay and i want you to actually own that
the fantasy of and i don't say fantasy
negatively but the picture that you had
of them
walking alongside you as you got older
is going to be very very different and
you don't know what that's going to look
like but it's going to be different
you have a dad who's struggling with
bipolar and deep
deep depression or loss of his daughter
and the challenges in his marriage
you've got a mom who's got a lifetime of
connection and being married to someone
bipolar disorder
who lost her daughter um and all of the
big and little t traumas that go along
with that you just your parents have a
lot on their hearts and minds
and you've got to just put a period at
the end of that sentence
okay yeah and owning that and dropping
your shoulders down and letting that be
truth is gonna hurt and it's gonna suck
and it's gonna be
heavy and it's something that you got to
do
okay okay it may look like writing them
a letter
that says here's what i remember
here's what i wish my childhood would
look like here's what i loved about you
guys
and then ending that letter with the
section on here's who i'm going to be
in light of the way y'all raised me
here's in light of
the woman i'm growing up to be the wife
i'm growing up to be
here's who i'm going to be and what
you're going to do there is you're going
to acknowledge the good stuff
you're going to nobly acknowledge the
bad stuff
and then you're going to set a
trajectory for where you're headed
okay that's number one number two
is sitting down with your mom if your
dad's got bipolar and he
doesn't take his meds and he's not
willing to be cognitively engaged
it doesn't help to have him a part of
the conversation if he does
if he is like you said doing better he
is taking his medication he's working
hard
working um to do the things he knows he
needs to do to stay well
it would be great to have him a part of
the conversation um
but you have a conversation with both of
them and say and say
and you are full within your
right as a child as an adult to have
this conversation
and say mom i cannot have you
threatening suicide ever again
okay that has to stop and let her know
you are wrecking me you're wrecking your
other kids
it hurts us when you threaten we cannot
lose somebody else in this family
if you are struggling mom if you need
help if you don't like our decisions
tell us that
but you cannot threaten suicide anymore
and the or is this
or i will call 9-1-1 every time
and i will tell them that my mom is
threatening to kill herself and she just
hung up the phone on me and she won't
answer the phone back
and they will send ambulances and they
will send the whole cavalry
your mom's going to be on the hook
financially for it and she needs to know
that people care about her and do not
play around with that
okay if she says oh honey you know i
would never do that
you know i just say it when i get mad
then that's when you also respond with
that is not acceptable that is not an
acceptable threat that is not an
acceptable joke that's not an acceptable
well i'm just mad i'm gonna start taking
it seriously
every time from this point forward and
let her know i don't have the skills to
handle that
i'm not trained as a psychotherapist i'm
not trained as a medical professional
so i will call 9-1-1 every time
period and letting her know up front
here's how we're going to do that and i
think framing it is
i do not want to lose another family
member i love you guys
yeah and you are well within your right
to draw that boundary
do you feel like you can have that
conversation
um i think it's something that i have
been known that i need to work up
towards
okay um and i might have to include um
my husband with that um because i have
a feeling it will not go over well or it
will blow up later
okay here's the thing it might and all
you can control in this deal is you
right and once you once you draw a
boundary
it's your responsibility to uphold your
in your side of the fence right
and think about it logically and it's
hard to think about it
just facts and figures wise if somebody
says
that's just who i am and a part of being
relationship with me
is accepting that i threaten suicide
every once in a while
right that doesn't sound that that
doesn't sound right right
yeah and i know it's your mom and so
backing out of it and hearing it that
way it's like
what no right and owning
both to yourself and to her i don't know
what to do when someone says that so i'm
just calling the people who are trained
um to intervene every time 100 of the
time
and i need you to hear me say what i'm
about to say and this is going to be a
hard thing to hear
and it's going to be a hard thing to say
but i'm going to be honest with you okay
yeah if your mom does go on to hurt
herself
if she does one day take her life that
will not be your fault
do you promise that you hear that from
me yeah
that will not be your fault your
responsibility
is to be honest with your mom to be
loving towards your mom
and to make sure that to the extent that
you can
that medical professionals and emergency
professionals know when she needs help
but if your mom ends up doing that that
will not be on you
okay okay and making that space for
yourself psychologically is important
doesn't sound like she's ever even
attempted it so anything you've told me
so far doesn't make me think that's
imminent
but i always think that's important to
put out there okay
yeah okay so the challenge is going to
be number one mourning
the loss of this picture and sometimes
into our 30s and 40s
we finally go oh this isn't going to
happen
right this isn't going to look like we i
thought it was going to look
and having to sit down and be okay with
that and sometimes that's a that's a
one-hour letter you write it you just
feel a million times better sometimes
it's a process sometimes it takes two or
three people sitting around a campfire
to talk about it
and sometimes it takes a couple of
months with a counselor to work through
it
um but going through the morning process
that your picture is going to look
different
your picture kayla's going to look
different and then
getting the courage getting the space to
have that hard conversation
is going to be critical and if your
husband's going to help that
conversation great
if he's going to complicate it and make
it harder then uh maybe he doesn't need
to be there but if he
he's gonna assist that your mom would
would love to have him there be there
plan this event don't just spring it on
him um
and if your dad's in a well space make
sure he's there too
but my heart's with you kayla i know it
sucks
i hate that you lost your sister
my i get a sense that you and i could
talk for a while and you've got a
history of some stories you could
probably
just lay out sequentially that would
suggest you've had a tough road to hoe
and i'm
i'm heartbroken for you and i'm also
proud of you for making the hard
decision to draw boundaries to love your
mom
and still move forward so good for you
kayla